I want to show um talking to cauterizing
wounds I want to show Maurice Maureen
can we get Maureen back for a moment I
don't know if you've seen this mooring
but the I just written the column for
the New York Post uh both of you me and
Douglas all right at the post
um I just uh written about Kim
Kardashian's derriere which has now been
appearing on the front cover of
interview magazine uh under the American
dream issue of interview we have to have
this apparently as the emblem of the
American dream Kim Kardashian's gigantic
naked backside bearing off the magazine
stance as an American do you see this
image as the personification of the
American dream
oh
uh you know it's a specific kind of
American dream I think it's a kind of
American dream that you know does share
something in common with Meghan Markle
when you are devoid of really any Talent
or intellectual contribution to make
what do you do you auto-generate your
content what is Kim Kardashian's content
it's her ever evolving
uncanny valley kind of physicality this
isn't even new she did this before uh
she was on the cover of paper magazine
and her her bum was you know out there
in uh greased up and it was shocking at
the time and I think that what is
probably going to be shocking to Kim
Kardashian is that these kinds of images
no longer they fail to shock any longer
exactly the only shocking thing is she
kept coming closer yeah I agree I
totally agree uh just mentioned I want
to just mention another story before we
finish with the pack this extraordinary
story of a school teacher in Ireland
who's been imprisoned after refusing to
use the pronouns requested by a trans
student Enoch Burke was initially
suspended by Wilson's Hospital School in
Dublin saying the request was a
violation of his Christian beliefs he
was then issued with an injunction and
told not to attend the school after a
public round with the head teacher but
he continued to show up he's now been
thrown in prison for contempt of court
Bert will now remain in prison until he
quotes purges his contempt effectively
apologizes or is Free by the court
Douglas Murray we've talked a lot about
free speech on this show you and I
at the heart of this I don't even agree
with half the things this teacher seems
to believe or or think but I I respect
his religious beliefs it's a religious
school by the way what I can't get my
head around is that somebody who refuses
to call a singular human being by the
way they which I have always found
Preposterous when there's one person
because he wouldn't use the right
pronoun he's now in prison
albeit for contempt but the contempt was
because he refused to back down on not
being required to use this pronoun what
do you make of that yeah of course some
people might have missed something very
interesting that's happened in Ireland
in the last couple of decades after the
church scandals of recent years Ireland
has effectively de-christianized faster
than any country I've ever seen but you
know you strip one religion out of a
country it doesn't mean the country
loses all sense of religion Ireland also
perhaps faster than any European country
I know has gone straight for the
religion of social justice warriorism
it's extraordinary to see it uh the way
in which it's vehemently advocated by
politicians of almost every stripe
including former terrorists uh and they
all jump into this they all jump into
the pronouns business uh a shin Fame
pretend that the armed struggle and
indeed Bobby Sands died for gay rights I
think Bobby Sands had been a bit annoyed
if you told him he was doing this for
the gays but anyway um they've Rewritten
their own history they've got this
massive religion of social justices and
there and and they're militant about it
they're quite as militant as they were
in the past about Catholicism yeah okay
I want to bring this to the victims yeah
be bringing Grace I mean just whatever
the debate about transgender and I don't
you know I have no problem showing full
respect for transgender people have full
rights to equality and fairness this
whole thing with pronouns the idea of a
teacher actually ending up in prison
because ultimately because he wouldn't
say to a trans attitude you're called
they that's not why was it well he was
because he's in contempt of course and
that's something for the court today
because he refused to he refused
institution but he refused to back down
on the principle of using a pronoun no
who cares if the kids the school cares
or he wouldn't be in prison day you know
the idea that Ireland's been like taken
captive by social justice
conversation
absolutely ridiculous Ireland is
suffering this crises like the housing
crisis that is one of the words
it's an employment matter it's not a
criminal matter when the bloke ends up
in jail again for the court to decide
like it's you know if he wants the if
the students
okay deal with islands
with the Water Crisis deal with the
wages don't waste time
all right Grace ever since the financial
question you've got to call me hot
that's my pronoun like a
certainly not a protected character
sorry sorry if it appears if you want me
my pronoun every time I come in the show
and you say grace I'm gonna let you talk
about whatever I'm gonna let you talk
about the economy you're going to call
me about that you're not talking about
Meghan Markle or pronouns are going to
let you talk about you'll call me comics
and climate change I'll call you
whatever you want but if you don't call
me hot you're going to jail well that's
that's the way this works if it's okay
with you I'm not going to call you
absolutely social justice Warrior it's
probably where I belong anyway isn't it
like my pronouns on my Twitter profile
are actually hot hotter hottest so just
for the record uh I'm actually not
joking they are my preferred pronouns um
Grace thank you good to see you Richard
thank you Douglas Maureen and New York
thank you both very much probably with
the finest peers pack we've had so far
so thank you for that transatlantic orgy
of intellectual intelligence much
appreciated